pues mi tema es hablar sobre la juventud
y a mí se me hace luego muy pretencioso
venir a dar consejos o platicar luego o
pretender que con lo que yo diga que el
frente ustedes van a hacer alguna
transformación o algún cambio yo por
esta misma razón a mí me gusta más
platicar de mi experiencia y les voy a
hablar un poco de mí ahorita al inicio
pues yo soy lagunero nacía hace 30 años
y lo digo con orgullo y con mi boca se
llena de orgullo cuando digo que tengo
30 años
y mi juventud pues mi juventud fue
peculiar fui un desmadre la neta yo fui
un alumno y soy maestro mis alumnos pero
si por ahí fui un alumno promedio me
divertí en mi juventud pero yo nací y yo
creo que muchos de los que estamos aquí
nacemos nací pues en un momento en el
que la juventud era gris no yo traía el
concepto de que los jóvenes eran
perdidos estaban perdidos que eran
y no les importaba que tenía un poco
interés y que eran un desmadre y que
vivían nada más la loquera de la
juventud porque veníamos de una
generación que eso nos habían dicho una
generación perdida mucho tiempo después
ya mucho tiempo después casi a los
veintitantos encontré el concepto
millennial y dije bueno el ser rebelde
ahora tiene un concepto al ser diverso o
diferente ir contracorriente ahora ya se
llama millennial entonces eso a mí me
dio como esperanza no ya se me ponen un
concepto si no ponen un nombre ya quiere
decir que estoy dentro de los libros
entonces no estoy perdido
soy millennial los millennials estamos
entre los 35 y los 20 años no entonces
por ahí tengo este un alivio pues
pero bueno
a los 15 años 16 años yo no sabía que
quería hacer de mi vida encuentro el
teatro a los 17 años y tengo que
confesar que soy actor gracias a que mis
papás no querían que fuera actor no yo
un día dije yo quiero ser actor tengo 14
años haciendo teatro lagunero mucho
teatro y un día dije quiero ser actor y
mi papá mi hijo te vas a morir de hambre
y eso como era joven ya rebelde me hizo
estar en contra del hijo ahora huevo soy
actor vea porque los jóvenes estamos en
contra de los papás eso es lo que nos
enseñan y gracias a eso tengo mucho
tiempo haciendo teatro
he visto cómo el teatro lagunero crece
el teatro lagunero ha crecido mucho en
el 2004 2007 que empecé a actuar así
había unas 5 producciones por aquí tengo
compañeros teatreros había 5
producciones 6 producciones al año ahora
tenemos 56 producciones al mes entonces
me da gusto decir que soy parte de esa
camada de actores que está desarrollando
en la es la cultura la manera pero bueno
fui creciendo y esta rebeldía de la
juventud me hizo divertirme ser feliz
fui muy feliz e hice todo lo que podía
hacer los jóvenes pero hasta que cumplir
30 años 27 años en realidad voltea mi
pasado y dije cabrón tenía tanto poder
cuando era muy joven y lo aproveché para
mi beneficio propio
hace tres años estoy a la cabeza de la
asociación cívica la laguna que es una
institución que ayuda a promover el
liderazgo en los jóvenes trabajo ahorita
ahorita estoy trabajando con 260 jóvenes
que a su vez ellos están trabajando con
más jóvenes y que para mí es un orgullo
que esté no hay aquí y cuando yo he
platicado que que trabajo con jóvenes
mucha gente me dice no te da hueva oye
si cierto que la juventud ahora es
apática hoy sí es cierto que tienen poco
interés los jóvenes y les digo sí sí
cierto sí es cierto tienen poco interés
son apáticos pero por qué no
dado cuenta del potencial que tienen
como jóvenes después yo les digo a los
27 años regreso a mi pasado y digo esto
chingón pero pude haber hecho más y
entonces es lo que a mí me gusta
promover platicar a los jóvenes qué es
lo que pueden hacer porque porque a mí
no me lo dijeron no a mí nada más me
hicieron así son los jóvenes rebeldes
egoístas un desmadre van a encontrar los
papás no gracias a eso soy héctor les
hilo esto es a mí me gusta pues promover
les o invitarles a que aquí sean
conscientes del entorno en el que
vivimos y del poder que tiene la
juventud vivimos en un país en el que
mueren siete mujeres al día siete
mujeres diarias mueren tenemos 68
desaparecidos diarios de enero a
septiembre de 2017 10 68 personas
desaparecieron en nuestro país y de esas
68 aparecieron siete mujeres muertas
diarias
y hollywood es un tema que a mí no me
gusta vivimos en una ciudad en la que
tenemos una cama de hospital por cada
mil habitantes una cama de hospital
vivimos en una ciudad que tiene eso pero
en el país se replica la misma el mismo
promedio una cama de hospital por cada
mil habitantes japón o alemania tienen
trece catorce camas de hospital por cada
mil habitantes
entonces yo a veces les digo tú crees
que no hay cosas que hacer a ti te gusta
esa forma de vivir a ti te gusta creer
que sí tenemos una pandemia nos vamos a
morir todos porque no tenemos a dónde
meternos no hay hospitales te gusta eso
te gusta que tus compañeros mueran siete
de cada siete mujeres mueren alguien te
gusta esa realidad yo no yo yo los
invito luego que reflexionemos cuáles
son las necesidades de nuestro mundo de
nuestro país vivimos en un mundo que
está sobrepoblado al doble va a llegar
un momento en el que tengamos que irnos
a vivir a marte la mitad de los de los
ciudadanos porque no podemos vivir
nuestro mundo no nos resiste por aquí no
me van a dejar mentir el mundo no va a
resistir si seguimos sobre poblándolo
así
yo tengo una teoría y en unos años la
mitad se tiene que ir a vivir a marte
tenemos que matar a la mitad alguien me
escuchó y eso está haciendo ya nos
estamos matando el peor enemigo del ser
humano es el ser humano
estamos matando nos pasa en todo el
mundo en las vegas' un loco dispara a la
gente y entonces a mí me gusta ser
conciencia de bueno ok no te estamos así
porque quien no interviene quién es el
que falta intervenir en el país el
grueso de la población son jóvenes de
entre 18 y 24 años es el grueso de la
población y saben que son los que menos
saben salen a votar porque
inglaterra lo vivió el breve siento
decidieron los viejos y todo con todo
respeto para los viejos sabios que yo
los escucho van de sanidad
porque deciden por nosotros y nosotros
nos quedamos si el otro día estuve en un
panel que me invitaron me gustó que me
hayan invitado jóvenes de lerdo que
están haciendo transformación y una de
las preguntas que salta dice los
gobiernos tienen que tenerle miedo a la
juventud
yo me paro y luego luego digo si los
gobiernos tienen que tener el miedo de
la juventud yo estaba compartiendo el
panel con personas de municipios y
dependencias de gobierno yo digo si los
gobiernos tendrían que tenerle miedo a
la juventud ya cualquier sector de la
sociedad no sólo a la juventud pero más
a la juventud porque porque somos el
grueso de la población o son el grueso
de la población son quienes tienen que
tomar la decisión son los que se están
preparando pero saben por qué no nos
tienen miedo o no les tienen miedo
porque no hacemos nada porque no salimos
a votar yo estoy muy feliz y muy
contento por la comarca lagunera porque
en las últimas elecciones logramos en
algunas casillas de torreón coahuila
llegar hasta el 90 por ciento de
votantes eso es un hecho histórico y
saben que porque si estaba la gente está
la madre pero porque tenemos que estar
hasta la madre para hacer una
transformación social porque
cuando el panel este que les platico
sigue la gente del municipio decía no no
no tienen no tendríamos que tenerle
miedo los gobiernos a la juventud
tendríamos que trabajar en colaboración
y dije bueno se su trabajo tratar de
convencerme el municipio los gobiernos
los institutos municipales tratar de
convencerme de que tenemos que colaborar
no lo que tenemos que estar peleando ok
pero lo que me dolió es que tiene ese
panel había dos jóvenes más jóvenes que
yo jóvenes muy talentosos y que están
emprendiendo proyectos sociales uno se
levanta dicen en los gobiernos tendrían
que tenernos miedo y otros se levanten
dice que no
que no un joven de 21 años dice no no
tendríamos no tendrían que tener unos
miedos tendríamos que trabajar en
colaboración cabrón no hemos podido
trabajar en colaboración los últimos
años entonces ahora sí tenemos que hacer
algo y no los estoy mentiste invitando a
que nos manifestemos estoy invitando que
reflexionemos que el papel tiene en los
jóvenes o tenemos los jóvenes para hacer
la transformación social estamos hasta
la madre de que los viejos decidan
estamos hasta la madre de que los
gobiernos tomen las decisiones y son
gobiernos de viejos como motors el
primer joven independiente que sale
donde estamos los demás donde está es el
grueso de la población
en la parte social yo estoy muy feliz
con la juventud y lo vimos ahora en el
terremoto del 19 de septiembre me
encantó y yo lloré lloré en la
computadora primero por impotencia por
no poder dar mis manos y estar ahí para
ayudar pero más por ver a la gente en la
calle ayudando ese es el méxico que
necesitamos esos son los jóvenes que
necesitamos pero porque tiene que ser
ante la necesidad inmediata hasta que no
vemos una persona abajo de las piedras
entonces es cuando nosotros empezamos a
hacer una transformación social nos nos
volcamos hacia la comunidad hacia la
colaboración comunitaria ya cuando todo
el mundo está debajo de las piedras
porque no prevemos eso ahorita nos
decían que la tecnología pudo haber
prevenido muchas catástrofes en el
terremoto la ciencia y la tecnología
pero no lo hicimos donde están esos
ingenieros que pueden aportar esos
jóvenes vuelvo a lo mismo de un inicio
yo fue un cabrón que me la pasaba
vistiendo en la universidad saqué la
universidad y se conciencia de mi
realidad y ahora estoy aquí y ok mi
juventud fue muy fregona pero
pude haber hecho más por eso me vivo me
desvivo en invitar a los jóvenes a que
participen si se puede en el 2011 en
túnez en egipto existe un movimiento que
seamos la primavera árabe los jóvenes
salieron a la calle hacer esta
transformación los jóvenes fueron los
que dijeron ya estamos hasta la madre
este gobierno saben cómo se pusieron de
acuerdo por facebook la tecnología sirve
la tecnología se sirve por grupos
privados de facebook en egipto empezaron
a ponerse de acuerdo para derrocar el
gobierno de mubarak y luego saben que
como se dan cuenta que podían no les
gustó el nuevo gobierno que pusieron
hicieron otro nuevo otra vez cuando ya
no nos gustó ya ellos ya les gusta estar
cambiando el gobierno pues a mí me
encantaría que los mexicanos pudiéramos
sentir esa confianza de hacerlo se pudo
a mí me cuesta mucho trabajo creer que
en pleno 2017 en un momento en el que
nuestro gobierno tiene el peor nivel
reputacional de la historia uno de cada
10 mexicanos quiere el presidente que
tenemos
no hagamos un movimiento vuelvo a lo
mismo no les estoy invitando a que
salgamos a las calles y nos manifestemos
los estoy invitando a que hagamos algo
para hacer esa transformación en 1968
los jóvenes que convencieron a
enfermeras a actores a obreros a
maestros eran jóvenes pero eran jóvenes
de preparatoria 16 17 18 años sales a la
calle ahorita ves un pelado de 16 años
así no yo no sé cómo se va el cuerpo no
sé cómo nos vamos a ir adaptando va a
salir una joroba enorme aquí porque
vamos a estar aquí en el celular están
muy desinteresados de lo que pasa en la
actualidad vuelvo a lo mismo hay que
levantar la cara de sus celulares y ver
que cada 17 mujeres mueren al día que
tenemos una cama de hospital por cada
mil habitantes que dos de cada diez
mexicanos que entran a la escuela
terminan la universidad dos de cada diez
pelados que entra en la primero de
primaria van a tener un título
universitario eso es un número triste
muy triste pues qué pasa con nosotros 8
qué pasa con nosotros ocho mexicanos
tenemos cosas por hacer si tenemos
muchos pretextos para salir a actuar
ahora qué es lo que pasa porque no lo
queremos hacer porque tenemos que
esperar a que se caigan edificios para
salir todos corriendo en chingar a
ayudar gracias si eso está muy chingón y
estoy muy contento de que eso haya
pasado pero triste porque paso hasta ese
momento
así que tenemos que hacer los jóvenes
que tenemos que hacer los adultos los
que tenemos 30 años para impulsar a los
jóvenes a la transformación social yo
siempre digo con la gente que trabajo
hay que hacer cambios pequeños también
hay que pretender hacer los grandes
proyectos pero hay que hacer cambios
pequeños no jal nunca nunca hay que
dejar de soñar yo nunca he dejado de
soñar a los 17 años soñé que podía ser
actor por llevarle la contra mi papá sí
pero ahora que soy actor y que puedo
impactar de muchas maneras en el arte me
gusta ir más allá y salir a las calles y
decir oye sueña oye a salvo tú puedes a
mí me hubiera gustado hacer más a lo
mejor por eso soy bien necio
porque me hubiera gustado hacer más que
lo que hice aunque lo que hice estuvo
padre pero me hubiera gustado hacer más
los jóvenes tienen el poder vivimos en
el país y vuelvo a lo mismo que somos el
grueso de la población vivimos en un
país que hay muchas carencias y muchas
necesidades
vamos a hacer un cambio que los
gobiernos de tengan miedo a la juventud
por favor que le tengan miedo que
tiemblen ante ustedes ante nosotros y
que digan a ver los mexicanos no son
mediocres ni son pasivos los mexicanos
quieren hacer el cambio tenemos muchas
cosas por las que salir a las calles y
hacer cambios sociales transformaciones
sociales cooperación es no dejemos que
las crisis nos hagan volcarnos a la
ayuda hay que prevenir no hay que ser
reactivos hay que ser una sociedad que
previene las catástrofes que previenen
las crisis y por favor confíen en el
poder que tienen como jóvenes yo digo
que soy joven tengo 30 años y yo voy a
decir no me siento de 30 y siempre lo
digo aunque mis 30 años fueron bien
vividos vivan cada uno de esos 30 años
pero no sean ajenos al mundo en el que
vivimos hay que recordar que vivimos en
un espacio compartido porque tengo que
cuidar está está esta tierra este
planeta porque no es mío porque es tuyo
también y lo comparto
y si alguien lo estaba dañando
deteriorándose lo está chingando con
toda la libertad del mundo puede decirle
oye tranquilo porque este espacio lo
compartes conmigo y porque yo quiero
hacer una transformación y quiero que
mejoren si ustedes les gusta vivir en un
mundo en el que siete de mujeres
desaparecen al día si ustedes quieren
vivir en un mundo en el que dos de cada
diez estudiantes terminan la universidad
si usted les gusta vivir en un mundo en
el que 60% de los mexicanos viven en
pobreza si usted les gusta viviendo un
mundo en el que hay una cama por cada
1000 habitantes pues adelante pero a mí
no me quiten mi espacio váyanse a
respirar a otro lado porque a mí me
gusta vivir en un mundo mejor